alright guys bangbang I'm super excited
about this got Phil here thanks for
doing this man oh my pleasure it's it's
an honor to be here so like I'm the one
who's appreciative yeah this is a gonna
be a little bit of a different episode
because we're not gonna spend so much
time on on finance or business related
stuff but uh you just have a really cool
story and I think that we can make some
some people get excited about walruses
so uh maybe let's start with your
background specifically and then we'll
get into kind of the fun stuff but just
like where'd you grow up and kind of all
those early life like I'm from a small
southern Ontario city called Welland in
Canada and not a particularly well-known
city other than maybe stands out for
being a rough a little rough so and I
sort of got my lumps there and
eventually graduated to the medium-sized
city tourist trap of Niagara Falls which
is where I would I would eventually find
my my employment that's what was
regarded as one of the more noted
tourism places called Marineland and
maybe we should if we want to back it up
a little bit I suppose I can speak to
what it is that led me to my employment
at Marineland but there's really not
much to say I was sort of one of these I
guess I didn't really know what it is
that I wanted to do some people are born
and they know they want to be
chiropractors I was born and I just knew
I'd like to be outside and run around
you know be a bit of a [ __ ] disturber
and whatnot so you know in all of my
sort of in my in my lost state of being
sort of fell ass backwards into this job
that's you know back then you looked in
the want ads so I was looking in the
want ads and I found a marine mammals
assistant trainers job I thought you
know it'd be a probably an impossible
job to get but
you know I did go to school for at the
time it was one of these six-month
programs audio engineering and
multimedia post-production it was called
back then and in 2000 cost me a lot of
money and about eight months later it
was a free download on the internet all
of the software that I learned on but
nonetheless is marine life found that
attractive on my resume so you know
whereas I thought I was not qualified
for such a job they thought you know we
can we can use you in-house to do some
of the music production and work on the
equipment and then you know you seem to
like animals so this would be a fit and
you know that was back in 2000 and if we
fast forward a little bit
in 2012 I quit
you know I was a long time to work at
Marineland of course there's you know I
did love animals tough topic to leave
but fast words then some and here we are
2020 and I'm still being sued for 1.5
million dollars for plotting to steal a
walrus and go alright so hold on a
second give us understanding for those
that don't know what marine land is how
people just understand kind of you know
what is the organization and then what
does it actually look like on the ground
so you know marine lines been around a
long time in candidates it's actually
one of its success stories and
immigrants had come to Canada with a
little more than a shirt on his back and
by the name of John holder was his was
the founders name he recently passed
away a couple years ago but nonetheless
he built this place from the ground up
you know with little or no help from
anybody it's really quite an it's quite
a success story
the unfortunate of fact matter of fact
is the this style of business that he
created is not one that is you know in
2000 it doesn't have a place in 2020 so
the man started with with a welding a
cage and bringing in some sea lions and
then eventually that graduated to larger
land animals he began to expand his
business he basically had a massive zoo
and then he found his niche which were
whales and
so much like SeaWorld in the States its
marine line is just a place where you
pay money to go watch whales and
dolphins and walruses and sea lions
perform to music and in 2012 and quite
frankly up until in 2000 and up until
2012 this was a celebrated industry you
know it really was it was a thriving
burgeoning business but you know not so
much today for sure
and so while you were there like what
did you see
and was this like immediate from from
when you got sorted or did it take some
time for you kind of get a little and
what did you see there just kind of you
know really put you off I guess so I
would say the first thing the first day
that I showed up I was completely put
off I couldn't believe what I was seeing
I mean I found the facilities to be
awful and I mean frankly I thought the
animals were sad but then I didn't want
to be anthropomorphic I mean I didn't
know nothing about whales so I didn't
want to just attribute these emotions to
what appeared to be sadness to me but
you know these people that I was
learning from seemed to have a grip of
what was going on and they seemed to
know that you know a thing or two about
this and this was a celebrated industry
so I didn't well I don't want to
question much especially in my like
earliest of 10 years you know earliest
days they're just a 22 year old kid I'm
not gonna chime in I mean sure I had
questions but it was evident that people
weren't there
the people there weren't asking a lot of
questions so I'm day one it was kind of
tough day 2 day 3 day 4 day 5 you become
yourself desensitized to you to your
environment mm-hmm years 6 years 7 you
become an apologist for hurt or rather
you you rather you you even defend it
but then year 8 9 10 as you climb the
ladder and you become closer to the
decision-makers can you yourself are
supposed to lend your thoughts and
experience the decision-making I was
always in the corner of the animals and
so my clash came with management and for
me the bewilderment came when you know
things that seem so obvious we're just
being refuted in in in lieu of things
that
more profitable or perhaps just not
someone else's idea it
the thing about Marineland is it really
is a place that is unique unto itself
and how it was managed its kind of micro
managed by its founder not a lot of
things happened without him having to
know and the problem with that is you
know if he's not available and something
is you need some eminent attention
whether it be mechanical failures or
animal em animals and distress it could
make for a very stressful environment
like what would be an example where
you're saying you know hey look that the
trade-off was in your opinion obvious
but maybe they didn't agree well for
instance I found that you can get a lot
more out of an animal if you can train
them over a long period of time
establish their trust and that would
require a lot more time with the animal
like hands on a lot more staff and
whatnot let's say let's use a medical
training medical procedures as an
example rather than then drop an entire
pool of water down to inches and have
say 13 to 20 beluga whales on their
stomach bouncing and thrashing and
cutting themselves up and bleeding
profusely and and trainers getting
injured because we're trying to do
injections or trying to draw blood why
not train those animals to voluntary
amongst it voluntarily do so which is
totally possible this would be an
example of class for me so I would say
to management look it would just take me
some time and investment but we can do
this and it's gonna be you know it's
gonna have less impact on both trainers
and animals and they saw it as well we
can get it all done in an hour and cost
us maybe some monies and medication and
whatnot but you know they just things of
that nature things of that nature got it
and then at what point does smushy come
in to come into the picture so suddenly
there's rumor that we're gonna get these
wild walruses in that marine that we've
never had walruses before but you never
knew what was coming I mean there was
just days where you'd show up to work
and you'd have some new wild caught
dolphins in your possession I mean this
was you just never knew so the rumors
proved fruitful and one day we received
two
walruses it wasn't in fact slooshy yet
but these these were our first two and
then came multiple shipments of multiple
more some would die fairly immediately
and then be replaced where are they
coming are they coming any people are
capturing them in the water
captured in Russia everything you read
the news with work with regards to Rheem
amell's and whale captures it's coming
out of Russia there's a there's a
burgeoning market in China and Russia is
trying to fuel that market so in China
they're erecting new facilities left
right and center and they're buying
these wild cut orcas and beluga whales
and what an walrus is in fact from
Russian brokers you may have saw in the
news last year there was a massive whale
rescue where you know an excess of 100
belugas in and orcas were forced to be
released by the Russian government after
activists sort of revealed that they
were staying in this crazy prison so you
know for a while it was it was global
news so you know it was quite an
impactful impactful time but nonetheless
the relationship that we had with the
Russians is that if we got beluga whales
or or walruses if one were to die within
I don't know the period of time it would
just I just recognized it as pattern
another would come back as replacement
so it's kind of a strange weird thing in
fact I mean I'll keep the story short I
did I first quit my job over a baby
walrus that was imported and I saw this
baby wasa and I thought geez this has
this animal has no we should not be in
possession of this animal it's a it's
half dead it's scared out of its mind
every time we go near to try to treat
him medically it looks like it's dead
you're gonna die from shock I was just I
was just so disillusioned by it so I
quit and then the next day I felt this
absolutely awful for having a band in my
teammates because you know you form
bonds in these weird environments with
the people you work with and so I came
back and and volunteered in fact to do
the necropsy on the baby
the walrus and so the veterinarian I'm
sorry Oh what city cropsy yeah that's
it's the same as a as an autopsy for a
human you're just gonna you're gonna
getting anything fine you're gonna go
through the the organs and drop blood
and different you know get samples of
different things and so what the
veterinarian wanted was justice justice
a blowed the baby walrus is brain and so
there I was with a chisel and hammer and
I felt like look I'll volunteer myself
for this because sort of this sign of I
don't know I guess a form of weird
punishment but I felt like you know what
if I'm I should do this and so I did and
it was you know weird and awful things
but nonetheless I went off topic as far
as smooshy is concerned so so suddenly
this these walrus comes in to our
possession and one day you know every
time we get green animals as we call
them so wild Cod just untrained because
they don't voluntarily present their
tails or whatnot to draw blood from you
have to physically sort of sort of
manhandle them and and tackle them to
get blood so that you can do an initial
health assessment and so in the process
of doing that we were sort of wrestling
down one walrus while smooshy was was
just had become frantic and and you know
walruses are just are protected by
nature she's trying to protect the other
walrus that we were trying to get the
blood from and so she was so disruptive
that I just decided to break away from
the group and try to get her out of
there she's you know she was about 200
pounds at the time which may not seem
like it's a hell of a thing to wrestle
so I was trying to wrestle her away but
something happened in that moment
between the interaction of swushi and I
that scientists have described it as an
imprinting so her brain circuitry open
suddenly everything that I am is now
tattooed on her brain much like in the
wild when a herd animal so rule is used
walruses as an example are amongst
thousands the mother and calf are able
to identify each other amongst all that
noise and chaos because of an imprinting
so all of my sense is everything that I
am so my smell the sound of my voice
everything it imprinted on her so she
recognized me sudden
as her mother so you can imagine the
conflicting this would be for someone
like me who you know while I like the
job I also as you know things as things
become more and more difficult find
myself in a situation where I've got a
relationship with an animal that is it's
gonna sound crazy but you know I have a
maternal like relationship I it's a very
powerful thing and it's a strange thing
for me to have to describe but she sees
me as her mother and consequently you
know I sort of I raised her in ways and
we had a level of communication that is
unique to human and animals we
communicate differently she's like she's
family to me it's it's a strange thing
to say I know but you have to understand
where I'm coming from it explain what
you mean by that right when people hear
that they're gonna be like that's crazy
but like what like actually explain when
you say that the way that you
communicate with an animal when you have
that close bond like what exactly does
that mean she understands my sense of
humor I've had other animals that
understand me in my sort of my
mannerisms and you know if I elevate my
voice then they think okay it's like a
heightened state of emotion there's a
response from an animal in smoochies
case she knows when I'm kidding she
knows
something that happens when an animal is
protective of you as well like the best
I guess a good example would be how much
do you love your dog for those who have
dogs that are really really really those
loyal and protective ones they become
family members well in the case of
smooshy it was more than that she
actually saw me as her mom like a
natural phenomenon just by virtue of
that it just does something so yeah we
just have a greater level of
communication and understanding she we
we understand each other better I know
it sounds crazy
it's nonverbal of course I'm not saying
when she says hoof I'm like she that
means mommy I'm saying like you know you
can understand an animal's level of you
know animals with that experience that
we perceive experiencing emotional and
it's tough place to venture into it I
mean I lean more towards there's no
question about it when they're
heightened do you understand it you know
you can appreciate whether they're
experiencing fear or whether they're
experiencing excitement what not with
smoochie it just was so much more acute
for sure and I guess as um as you were
kind of going through this and building
this bond is it something where like
you're in charge of just this one animal
or are you still caring for multiple
animals not just water system but than
other types of species as well it was
just this one you had the close bond
with right so what I what I did fail to
mention in that is when when I was
mentioned earlier that walruses were
coming in in various states of health
smooshy came in and wasn't well and so
my first maybe month or so was dedicated
to her because she had imprinted on me
my days were spent quite literally
sleeping next to her while she was
resting and getting her medication and
just getting her strength up and whatnot
so initially I did spend a lot of time
but of course I got to stretch myself a
little bit thin too because I've got
literally another hundred animals to
work with and you know you work in an
environment where we're already
stretched then especially in the winter
where Marineland is actually closed to
the public so you know staffing Reed
gets reduced and whatnot but you know
it's doesn't always go over well with
the coworkers one guy gets to sleep
des and the other one's got a scrub [ __ ]
off bars so I mean it is what it is we
got through it not would it be fair to
say like a lot of people have probably
watched a tire King the the recent met
flicks documentary and in that there's a
number of scenes where they have the
tiger cubs and there's a human taking
care of it and obviously that tiger cub
learns to recognize that human kind of
understands that hey they took care of
me and I'll call it they're kind of
friends to some degree and as they get
bigger and bigger next thing you know
you know you got a tiger that's four
hundred pounds and it's still treating
this human as if you know hey this is my
friend right doesn't attack it it kind
of plays with it it's responsive to it
etc it sounds like a lot of what you're
talking about here is that early bond
that you have then translates to kind of
the walrus version of that relationship
right know the difference between my
relationship with swooshy and that of an
animal that a while that it was just
familiar with the language of training
which is you do good I feed you I mean
that's a symbiotic relationship as long
as you don't turn your back on these
animals over time it should you know you
should keep all your limbs but no
smooshy that imprint is a completely
different thing that's where if she's
not literally beside me I mean that this
moment right now she's thinking about me
I know it sounds crazy but she is it's a
it's a level of obsession that I've
never known and now I actually was able
or rather than I was able to relate to
the other animals because now I better
understood what it meant for them to be
torn apart from their family members and
taken into captivity because I
recognized the inherent fear and the
thing that made animals in captivity
different than those of the wild but
with smooshy because by virtue of being
close to me in proximity she didn't have
that same sort of you know because I was
I filled the void of that missing mother
and that bond that this world sort of
became normal to her it's a weird thing
to explain but yeah it's a it's not the
same relationship as as someone that
feeds an animal or worked with an animal
a lot it's well beyond that it's almost
inexplicable it's she genuinely thinks
on her mom yeah
that's crazy um and so at what point do
you kind of get fed up on the Marineland
something you're like hey I gotta make a
change here so I was conscious enough
that the relationship with smoochie was
such that if I were to leave it was
gonna compromise her health so I did my
best in at least the last year or so to
try to wean off her dependence from me
because there was a there was a
dependence but you know we did work that
off and I was always conscious of not
leaving until that was something that I
was comfortable this is kind of I was
always balancing that but then in 2012
at the end of our operating season so
let's call it August there was a there
was a breakdown on the water
disinfection unit a ozone generator is
what the the machines called it
generates ozone and ozone when worked in
conjunction with chlorine mitigates
chlorines use you don't have to use so
much so the idea is in conjunction you
keep your water clean you don't have to
use so much chlorine the animals don't
have the adverse effects because
chlorine is as I'm sure you can relate
you know anytime you've ever jumped into
a pool that was shocked and you didn't
know yeah you know it can be awful so
animals living in that 24/7 it's it's an
awful thing so you know we started to
call the founding they know the owner
John holder and would say listen the
hose weren't generators broken water's
gone green we got to get something done
here
I can't rationalize his decision-making
but I'll assume that you know because
the season was closing it was was you
know it wrapped up in September that or
rather in October that this was
something that could be put off because
the park would be closed for a number of
months and they could just be addressed
that the problem with that was the water
had gotten so bad I mean it was evident
I mean the water had gone completely
green and I mean we can go into the
details that you know there is some
evidence on the internet I encourage
everyone as usual to do some some
research but he just wasn't gonna fix it
it just we couldn't get him you know I
would see him at local Tim Hortons
coffee shops and I've got animals whose
eyes are bleeding and his only answer
the answer rather was to increase
chlorine use over the months that we
were closed and it was awful it was
awful the the effects were awful and is
that a feistel is that a financial
decision or is it being driven by
something else
I'll say it's financial in addition to
the fact that some people can't be told
what to do and when too many people are
emphatically trying to tell someone what
to do just some people just elect to not
do that I can't explain why all I know
is the complacency was unjustifiable and
so two weeks prior to the following
season's opening day I said I ain't I'm
not I'm not I'm not I'm not part of
Marineland anymore I don't go on that
stage
I don't bring animals in this condition
oh I don't do this no more I'm [ __ ]
done and so I insisted on an exit
meeting and you know we exchanged
unpleasantries and pleasantries but I
wouldn't have quit without the the firm
agreement that I was to remain in
smooshes life if she needed me which
historically she had Marineland agreed
so much so that even one week later
because after I'd quit Marineland so
after the exit meeting he very
frantically dumped the water actually
delayed the opening of the park but he
got the message when I left it called me
back in to treat a dolphin because a
dolphin stopped you know soon as you
change a wild animal or captive animals
environment thinking little bit spooked
they stopped eating so he had he like
the owner specifically had me come in to
give a dolphin valium and Valium in the
zoological settings at least with marine
mammals will stimulate appetite and so
we administered the valium and you know
she was bouncing back I saw smooshy I
was certain not to let smooshy actually
see me because I you know I'd been gone
in in excess of a week now and it's
pretty long time so I didn't want to
disrupt whatever progress they were
having with her but I did see her and I
left but I was about a month later that
you know I wasn't in the best place
frankly I mean I should emphasize that
when I quit it was also in interest of
my of my mental health I wasn't in the
best of shape either but a month later I
just decided you know what it's been a
month now I'm gonna go see smoochy when
I tried to get back
the park for some reason the security
guard wouldn't let me in it's the
strangest thing because of the [ __ ] man
I was like family over there so uh
stroke of luck the owner's son who's a
good friend of mine I happened to see
the interaction with me in the security
guard and uh you know he escorted me in
well while I was coming into the park
where the veterinarian's drove around
the back and she she you know she met up
with me so Cherie that she'd been tipped
off that I was there I said what the
hell's going on and she said you're not
gonna like what she would you gonna see
I said let's go so she took me to the
back in what's called the warehouse or
the barn and took me immediately to go
see smooshy and there she was emaciated
bone dry
there was no fresh water there was no
ice on her deck I mean it looked awful
hikes so you know as soon as she
recognized me
she perks up I sent to the vet imagine
this I say go get meds so she's running
now we're filling fish with you know
various meds we start feeding her the
meds get her drink some water whatnot
mmm and as I'm leaving and I said to the
vet the [ __ ] happened why don't you call
me evidently the last time I was brought
in to feed the dolphin it worked one of
the new managers he didn't like that the
that the owner had gone over his head
and called me specifically so it's quite
political too nonetheless he was
determined that now Phil doesn't come
here anymore here's the new chain of
command of who calls Phil and it was
just sort of decided that Phil wasn't
gonna be called anymore and so I saw
that and what I didn't mention is at the
time some newspapers had been calling me
because you know back in 2008 when
smoochy showed up there was quite a bit
of media attention around she and i's
relationship there was a fluff story
that came out on Valentine's Day and it
was picked up by a bunch of media in
fact I was on like Jimmy Kimmel show
Inside Edition II went crazy at the time
when viral was yet you know was yet a
thing I was becoming MySpace viral let's
say so uh you know by virtue of having
had that attention and now quitting so
much of the media was like you know who
was the walrus guy gone [ __ ] happened I
was actually quoted in the 2000
article saying if I ever quit I'm gonna
take this walrus with me which I'm
reelin has yet to present as evidence in
court but nonetheless if I can help
their case any their non existing case
but yeah they started to call me and ask
me why I quit everything and you know
because my relationship with Marineland
was still firm and I intended to keep it
as such I I didn't talk but after seeing
smooshy in the condition that she was
here I picked up the phone I said you
put my [ __ ] name my face on every
[ __ ] newspaper and I could hear the
print machines going back okay fell
let's [ __ ] go a buckle up okay let's
do this and so you know massive expose
happen to drop on the owners birthday
you know things just got really ugly so
they sued me
and so expose like what were the main
allegations or her kind of claims if you
will well of note I wasn't the only
whistleblower there were seven of us
initially that grew to fifteen and then
it grew in excess of many of which
elected to speak anonymously because for
fear of legal reprisal because
Marineland is litigious just by they
have a long litigious history so you
know it described everything from lack
of staff issues to you know the water
breakdown there was incidences where the
owner was shooting neighbor's dogs I
mean it really quite just became an
expose surround around just a lot of
animal abuse sort of revelations and
whatnot just I mean Murray lads always
had a history but you know 2013-2014
with things like Twitter and whatnot it
just the landscape changed for a little
guy and so whereas they were accustomed
to just absolutely chopping everyone
down you know Here I am just luckily
sustaining but you know they just they
they they they employed their
strong-armed or corporate strongarm and
and they sued me with a slap suit and a
slap suited for those who don't who
weren't familiar the slap acronym stands
for strategic lawsuit against public
participation
basically they sue me to shut me up so
that the public doesn't get interested
in what the hell it is I have to say and
the King and the imminent change that
would come with it
and so I'm assuming that you thought
that this might happen but do you
remember when you first heard that the
lawsuit had actually been filed what
your reference this was great I thought
it could happen but I I've had enough
people in my corner naive Lee and
naively telling me that well if you're
telling the truth you can't be sued well
that's not necessarily true you you you
were unlikely to get a to get any type
of verdict against you but you could
certainly be sued so I had the sense
that you know maybe they would but I I
wasn't yet convinced but suddenly I
started getting calls from a friend of
mine saying let's look man they're gonna
serve me they're threatening I just got
you know I got served with this cease
and desist I got all this stuff they're
gonna sue me tomorrow and he's calling
me and tell me all this stuff I'm like
what that's crazy man the next day they
sued me by watching the news my friend
literally text me it's not me it's you
in capital letters look what the hell
and then I see that I missed a couple
calls from a from a journalist the funny
thing is you know you learn a thing or
two about journalism and all of this as
well in journalism at least back then
super corporate friendly journalism you
know you take a lawsuit then you take a
look you create all the greatest
headlines from it that you can because a
lawsuit is literally a legal means to
defame the [ __ ] out of somebody because
all you have to do is you know I sue you
for anything and the newspaper could
grab it run with the headlines to just
say you know and these allegations have
yet to be proven court so a corporate
friendly media will take we'll take
something that's been handed to them
before I'm even served about you that
take the sort of take the details of it
probably tip on what and what aspects to
point to and they call me one time let
it ring twice hang up so it was not
available at time for comment all they
have to do is send you an email and if
you don't respond to that you know
within two minutes and they do that call
with two rings it was rough it was
absolutely ridiculous
I found out I was being sued
I was learning about on the news it's
crazy
and so what point are you like alright I
should go steal a walrus
so the allegations of my plotting to
steal a walrus were in the lawsuit I
will say that they were there basically
to make me look like a crazy idiot and
that they could run with stupid
headlines because back and maybe the 90s
that would work maybe in the 80s that
would let's say in the 80s it would
definitely work but in 2012 just wasn't
gonna take so the idea that I would ever
have plotted to steal a walrus is absurd
but I should mention that by virtue of
being sued for millions of dollars and
now having sustained many years of
litigation through public support and
whatnot because you know there's a
number of campaigns here people that you
know you might not necessarily be an
animal lover but you might be like you
know [ __ ] the man you might be like you
know what give just you know keep this
guy fighting because I don't know it's
nice to have a lot of support there's
certainly a lot of reasons to keep this
thing going as best as long as we can
but that lawsuit they they [ __ ] up and
the problem is with lawsuits is there's
settlements and
you know that there's a good and evil
aspect to this but there's also an
[ __ ] versus [ __ ] aspect and you
know there was there was a big [ __ ]
in all this and then there's there's me
who is who might wind up being a bigger
[ __ ] because I'm a hard negotiator is
the only there's only one thing I want
so you can call it plotting to steal a
walrus or mop I didn't sue myself but if
they want if they want to get away from
this lawsuit there's only one way give
me the [ __ ] walrus I know it sounds
crazy
alright so the only way that you want to
settle this is if they give you smooshy
what the hell are you gonna do with the
walrus I have a place that's going to
build a facility will be ready in a
matter of months that is local that will
have two other walruses young female so
there's no no concern for for aggression
or or mating and whatnot and they have
they've declared themselves interested
and so Marineland has I mean the
unfortunate part about lawsuits
litigation and settlement talks is you
know there's an element of good faith in
negotiations but let's just say I can't
make it easier for Marineland so it just
becomes a question you know Merck sushi
is the last surviving walrus I should
mention in the last two years well now
now two and a little four have died I
mean whatever is happening at Marineland
right now and and it has forever but
it's just been exacerbated the animals
are dying off very quickly it's very
concerning marine lands conscious choice
to keep smoochy at the park is a
conscious choice to keep her in a state
of torture as far as I'm concerned and
so I'm trying to make it as easy as
possible for marine land and you know by
virtue of its gonna be it's gonna it's
been costing them and this is my
emphasis to them as whereas they say
something to the effect of what walruses
are very valuable I say well not a
walrus is costing you tens of millions
of dollars and I can with confidence say
that over the eight years I've been
removed tens of millions instead of like
part of what I don't understand right is
like the math and business behind all of
this so what
by that is like when that walrus shows
up as a baby walrus
it's Marineland like how much are they
paying for it and then what is the
ongoing cost just to feed it shelter it
and kind of take care of it so I don't
know the cost of the wild walrus I can't
even necessarily I can't even offer what
wild dolphins or or belugas cost I just
I don't want to be wrong about it and I
don't I just don't know but the care is
our ballpark basis are we talking a
couple thousand dollars or like half a
million dollars per animal if you had a
gasps if I had to guess I think if
you're dealing with one beluga you're in
the near six-figure range but if you're
dealing with multiple than your it may
reduce the price a little bit so you
know with marine land we would get like
six to twelve per shipment for fighting
four or five times we've got them maybe
more a couple times before I got in
there and dolphins we'd received three
times from that mistaken
walruses four times often accompanied
with other shipments so I don't know
because they were talking about like
combo platters
I don't know intimacy you know it drives
a lot of the big business in Russia and
China as well right is they're grabbing
these animals out of the oceans in the
wild and then turning around and selling
them for tens of thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of dollars in a
market obviously there's a huge profit
margin there and so I'm assuming that
they're not putting them in the
equivalent of marine land or sea world
in China maybe they are but but I've got
to imagine that that's more food based
type at you know financial activity
rather than here in the US a lot of
that's going into I'm trying to build a
business around here by this animal I
take care of it and then I actually
bring people into the park and have them
kind of watch shows and things like that
right the idea at least with Marineland
and their tried tested business model
and remember the owner was very was an
older man I mean we're talking about an
old school dude who's this was his baby
so you can imagine why he wouldn't want
to necessarily adopt and
type of positive change or evolve much
he almost he almost took the stance and
even ramped up his purchasing of wild
animals but yeah the sista used to be a
draw the door if you had an orca in a
pool you were going to make a lot of
money so it was worth paying at least a
lot of money in medication you'll notice
you know facilities in North America
haven't changed by the way if you take a
look at SeaWorld you take a look at
marine Landon you never noticed that the
pool you don't hear of new large
expanses you just never do you ride yes
new this but you know it's an old-school
idea with no place in 2020 if today we
were gonna start and build much like
China is these facilities I don't know
that like imagine if we were start from
scratch we could say hey I've got this
Marvel idea I'm gonna take that majestic
animal put in the cage every would be
like no that's not happen it's just
absolutely absurd a case couldn't be
made for it and yet today and yet these
facilities they still exist they're all
like 30 and 40 years old but the pools
haven't changed I think so you know
they're still stuck in the idea that you
fill the pools you fill the stands but
you know legislation is catching up to
them as well
can the sorry probably what's that say
do you think we'll see them shut down
like Marineland SeaWorld do you think
eventually they get shut down and
outlawed or do you think they don't it's
kind of morph what they look like so
what you'll see is they do have a shelf
life just by virtue of animals having a
shelf life whatever for whatever laws
come around so let's use in Canada for
example breeding important export of
whales dolphins and porpoises have been
outlawed it's bad it's a new law that
was passed only a few months ago I'd
like to thank Marineland for their help
in helping me pass that law by the way
and so by example
Marineland now has to care for the
animals because they can't get anymore
so the same thing you can imagine is
gonna happen I believe New York State
has some laws California has done the
same I imagine maybe at the federal
level and the states I mean it's all
going to catch up but you know people
vote with their dollars that's the
bottom line and no one wants to really
go to these places if you notice these
facilities are really suffering I mean
everyone's suffering right now but back
it up
even just a mere months ago see CEOs are
it's a rotating door at SeaWorld CEOs
because no one can come up with an idea
to keep these things going and any new
ideas are immediately rejected because
there's just an old guard that is
unbreakable with this particular
business and like you know you mentioned
Tiger King earlier because who doesn't
but you know these these owners are
really eccentric people they just really
are it's across the board I'm gonna say
it I'm gonna generalize the load of them
zoo owners and aquarium owners which
some of the wackiest people I've ever
come across I have to say so you know
nothing surprises me with the way with
all these you know hearing all the
stories of litigation exactly of course
yeah it's it's pretty crazy man when you
start to see some of this stuff one last
thing I want to talk about is you've
done a number of really interesting kind
of fundraisers and things to not only
one fuel the litigation that you're
engaged in but also on top of that to
really bring awareness to a lot of these
issues and and obviously smooshy is is
one piece of that but but a broader
issue as well maybe talk a little bit
about just how you've thought through
kind of you know the critical thinking
and outside the box thinking that's
required to you know really kind of rise
above the noise and a lot of these
situations so I will just go back to the
day I decided to speak out I was laying
on my bed rocking back and forth in a
fetal position and I said to myself hey
how am I supposed to live the remainder
of my life if I don't do something here
what does the rest of my life look like
and how do I live with myself i I just
couldn't I couldn't conceive not not
doing something and so by virtue of like
I guess the way I say it is I gave
myself up to the universe what I said
was you know no one stands a chance in
this fight me included so if I've got
nothing to lose and I should mention
that at the time I had just won $50,000
it sounds crazy I everything I say
sounds crazy I went on this this reality
TV show called white boat you may be
familiar the big red balls and all that
stuff well there was a kid owes a
short-lived version Canadian version and
I was
on it the premiere episode because I was
The Walrus mom and I won so when I got
that 50k you know I got it because the
walrus in my mind I kept saying to
myself well I wish I'd said to myself by
Bitcoin but said to myself you know it's
not really my money like it's it's an
easy thing to say hey go go buy yourself
something fancier or not but you know I
was just in such a state of sort of
distress and everything was just sort of
precarious situation that real and I
thought you know I better hold on this
for a rainy day so I at least at the
onset of the lawsuits and everything
else and and the decision-making that
went forward I thought I've got 50k this
is my money to get out of the gates
we'll see how long this lasts and if I
can keep going then I'll keep going
and so I I started with the fifty and
then you know launched some various
GoFundMe campaigns and whatnot to
sustain throughout and you know I still
have one
Midas oh by the way then just to back up
my decision moving forward and my state
of mind of thinking outside the box was
this in every which possible decision
presented be the most costly and pain in
the ass for Marineland that I can be in
every which way and the unfortunate part
of that is that I have to give myself
away often I always have to play the
role of this bravado guy well I'm
fill-in my pants but you know I just I
just decided do the exact thing that
scares the [ __ ] out here the most and
it's exactly what I've done and I have I
have been I've gone broke three times
I've been on the edge of absolute
disaster I've gone you still may be
crazy but still sustaining and somehow
and it is truly in the belief that
and if I just keep keep fighting
I mean I've got nothing to lose anymore
anyway so I do have a website a
fundraising website it's at save smooshy
calm I'll spell it out SAV e sm o shi
calm there's a trailer on there too a
documentary that's coming out I've been
followed for the last in excess of two
years both you know fighting for this
legislation in Canada and my flight
first smooshy and whatnot so you know in
that that's coming out on May 28th in
Canada on the CBC which is our national
broadcaster and that's only because it
was selected for the hot dogs hot dogs
International Documentary Film Festival
but you know it's been delayed and
whatnot so so you know CBC partnered
with with hot dogs so they're actually
gonna premiere it in Canada but isn't
geo lot to Canada but thereafter I
believe the plan is a theatrical run
maybe in the US and then us distribution
via you know whatever whatever it is so
you know look out for that what are we
yeah what do we put the odds at right
now that uh let's say by the end of 2020
one you have smooshy what was the
probability of that there was a I was at
1% when I quit if that I was on the I
was just honored and right now in my gut
I think
I mean it's a question of her staying
alive but if she stays alive if she
stays alive she will see me I'm given
that a ninety-nine percent IRR will I
get her I'm gonna give it 51% in the
next
in the next six months I'll know
now we are and you got a shot we are oh
[ __ ] yeah we got a shot I we're in a
part of litigation right now that they
don't want to be so they have some
really hard decisions to make I'm trying
to make it as easy as possible but if
they want to continue to embarrass
themselves and cost themselves down the
road then I'm I'm here to I'm here for
that like I love it so do you think that
anyone's told smooshy yet if I told you
what my ayahuasca journey I breathed
life into those nostrils I squeezed that
heart but I told her she knows I'm here
because of it I love it
all right so for those that want to to
figure out more about smooshy learn more
about kind of the bigger picture here of
just it really just comes down to animal
cruelty and a lot of things that are you
know becoming more apparent and obvious
that they're inhumane I mean in the
treatment of some of these animals you
can go to Sage smooshy calm and it's a
save than s mo Oh Shi correct correct
calm and also friends don't let friends
go to murrayland SeaWorld so spread the
word friends don't let friends go to
SeaWorld or marine land I love it yeah
man oh yeah and I think the next court
appearance you know like the duck
realize lawyer will be listening to this
and he will take issue so whether I wear
it or not we'll see you know much of
what I do is again just being a pain in
the ass but I got this new shirt I'm
making called lawyer destroyer I'm gonna
wear it under my butt shirt that's
something or I'm not if you go into a
courtroom and you wear a shirt this is
lawyer destroyer
there better be a video my attire has
been complained about in court before
anyways much of what I do gets
complained about in court but it's not
getting them I love it I love it alright
Phil listen I appreciate you taking the
time to do this you obviously have a
very different but but pretty crazy and
and impressive stories so I think that
more people hopefully will what kind of
look into this and here in the United
States it's very obvious that there's a
lot of kind of animal cruelty at at
these organizations and some of this
being addressed some of it's not but
there's very few people who are willing
to kind of dedicate their their time and
energy to this for all the people who
who love animals thank you but I'm just
appreciative for all the support man I
got the best seat in the house so I
thank everyone and you especially man
every opportunity to spread word like
this is you know it's it's it's all I've
got you know it really is this is it's
me against I'm against the machine so I
appreciate that that there is a machines
for me to fall back on the lawyer
Destroyer strikes again yeah all right
thanks Phil my pleasure man anytime